[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the pots Moving and Storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today we're
going to be talking to you about your
life and your money it is a free call
the phone number is
[Music]
888-825-5225 that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five Caesar starts
this hour in Chicago hi Caesar how are
you
I'm doing great you know what that's
Cesar is it Cesar or Caesar
Caesar it is like Julius Caesar got it
okay I did not mess it up good how can I
help
thank you so much uh yeah I'm 26 years
old tuned in from Chicago I have
approximately a hundred thousands in my
savings I have approximately 50 000 in
mutual funds that it's parked in a Roth
IRA Roth 401k and I feel like I have a
lot of options there's a lot of pressure
to buy I think I'm thinking about buying
the building and uh it's putting a lot
of pressure on me but it's a lot of
options I really don't know what to do
at the moment and I would like your
advice about my situation
do you have any debt
zero debt zero debt way to go are you
married
I am not married why isn't some woman
snapped you up that's right no there's a
woman trust me
yeah man you're killing it why are you
good you're killing it why are you going
proud of you
so is your personal is your personal
residence paid off as well
or are you a buyer yet
I am renting at the moment in Chicago
and this is my situation for renting
it's a two bedroom it's a thousand
dollars a month and I'm splitting it
with a roommate 500 each wow stole that
so you're not in a hurry to get out of
that no that's a deal I know so
they're not shooting down the street are
they
no no they're not actually they're not
sitting down the street
so what exactly is your question like
what are you hoping to get from this
call
okay there's a general question and
specific question I'm feeling a lot of
pressure to buy my own building a
multi-family unit home and to move into
position who's pressuring you um
you know that's a great question
it is
you know like
but that doesn't mean that's smart
um you know so I mean dude you you have
really good instincts you have really
good skills you are so far ahead of
normal normal sucks is broke has no
money I mean you got some money piled up
you've done a great job way to go uh if
you want to buy a condo to live in
that's fine but don't buy it because the
society the stupid thinks you should
right
okay you buy it because you got by
because you looked at it and you said I
like these numbers I mean you're the guy
living in a 500 rental situation in
Chicago
you're that guy right score you're the
smartest I know right you're the smart
guy be listening to him he's got more
going on so if you want to go buy you a
condo that's great you got a hundred
thousand dollars to put down and or you
need to set back an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
um and set back anything else you need
to purchase if you're thinking about
buying a car you're thinking about
buying whatever so that you don't go
into debt for the future items but after
that the rest of that money is your down
payment on a condo or whatever if you
want to buy something but but when you
say buy a building you know what I'm
hearing you've been reading real estate
investment crap on Tic Tac that's what
it sounds like
it's that my grandfather owns the
multi-family at home a lot of people my
circle you know a lot of a lot of them
uh the older generation owns a
multi-family unit home so I was thinking
why don't I house hack get a renter on
the top floor live on the first floor
and rent out the basement that's not a
bad idea but you should do it because as
you looked at it you thought hey that's
how I want to live
because the great news is your tenants
are attached to you the bad news is your
tenants are attached to you
exactly they're gonna be knocking on the
door at 2 A.M if they don't like
something unless you really set some
real clear boundaries it's very
difficult to manage a multi-family that
you live in from a boundaries
perspective uh so if you want to do that
that's fine there's nothing wrong with
that but there's nothing that says if
you don't do that that you're stupid
because you ain't stupid dude I know
that's right people need to be listening
to you instead of you listening to what
they're saying so if you want to take if
you want to take them you want to take
75 000 bucks what do you what do you
make
so I make approximately 75 000 a year
through my my full-time job and I also
own a business and what does it make
uh I'm combining the income from both oh
so you make 75 including owning a
business not awesome
so if you want to take 7500 leave 25 for
an emergency fund and you know you
continue out of your monthly budget
doing investing into your retirement
plan at your workplace then uh and you
want to go buy your multi-family and
live on the main floor there's nothing
wrong with that it's not a bad plan at
all but this idea that somehow
you know I I don't I here's here's a
good rule of thumb okay whatever
everyone else in America is doing do the
opposite and you'll probably have some
money true that now can I play devil's
advocate here why because I'm sitting
here thinking well here's my thought I'm
like okay if he was buying a personal
residence and he knows that he can
afford it without a rent without any
rentals you know just on his own great
but if he's buying this building that's
more expensive and he's depending on the
rent coming in should he not pay cash
for this property no no it wouldn't
matter if it's your residence and you're
going to take out a mortgage as long as
you can pay the payments and if you have
to have the rent to pay the payments no
that's what I want that's what my thing
with Caesar I want to make sure he
doesn't need the rent from the other
people living upstairs or downstairs you
don't go buy something that you can't if
your renters all don't pay you can't be
up a creek right so he's gotta you got
to be able to afford this regardless if
you ever enter a Caesar that's just a
little yeah
that'll keep because here's when you
have an empty apartment and you have to
make payments you become desperate and
when you become desperate right after
that you get stupid and that's when you
put the wrong tenant in and you create a
bigger mesh than an empty apartment
and so if you don't have to make the
payments if you don't have to have
somebody to stay alive right you know
inside the inside the unit there then
you make better decisions on who goes in
to the unit well he's got his family but
I'm also thinking your family is also
the ones that is like hey this month's a
little tight
give me till next month so there's just
a little there's a little stuff there
that he he might need to consider before
going in absolutely absolutely but
overall do it because it's the lifestyle
you want to live I want to live on the
first floor I'm going to do that at this
phase of my life I'm willing to deal
with tenants next door I'm not doing
this because my grandpa did it right
yeah I'm not doing this because I saw it
on Tic Tac that's we're not doing that
and um
you know until we arrived on the Tic Tac
scene about a month ago you could pretty
well say that whatever was said on there
was useless garbage we're trying to
displace it with some wisdom so I've had
a few things posted on there that did 10
20 million views and that kind of stuff
thank you guys I guess
um I think I should thank you I just
thank the people because they're making
the they're making the views go yeah
well I mean we got to put something good
on there to try to redeem the platform
but yeah but it's it's more full of get
rich quick crap than anything I've seen
since midnight cable
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
thank you to our audience you're
apparently telling other people that
we're here thank you our numbers are
going up in every format from YouTube to
podcast to radio thank you thank you
thank you we appreciate that uh we know
it didn't come up you come from anywhere
but you because we do not spend 300
million dollars on marketing like Sofi
instead we just actually help people
instead of screwing them and
um then you go tell other people so
thank you for that if you're new you're
one of those new people coming around
you're trying to figure out all this
lingo uh around the Ramsay thing where
are the baby steps and uh debt snowballs
and all this stuff you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the next best step in your financial
Journey it's completely free to do that
and we'll walk you through and what's
become famous around Ramsay was because
many many years ago decades ago people
came to me and they said what do you do
first do you do retirement first or do I
do kids college first that's very
important do I have an emergency fund
first that's really important I need to
get rid of this stupid credit card debt
it's 22 percent that's very important
where do I start and what we did at the
time many years ago was we laid it out
and then we adjusted it a couple times
in the early days we only adjusted it in
25 years but we laid out what to do
first what to do second one and we call
them the baby steps because if you eat
if you want to eat an elephant you do it
a bite at a time so if you want to get
control of your money you do it a step
at a time baby steps baby step one is
you save a thousand dollars quickly a
little starter emergency fund once
you've done that and some of you just
have that money you just name it that
just now you already did baby step one
you just reset that money in your mind
over to the side that's maybe step one
maybe step two is you pay off all of
your debt except your home using the
debt snowball
that that snowball is where you list
your debts smallest to largest pay
minimum payments on everything but the
little one you attack the little one
with a Vengeance you're not going on
vacation you're in debt you're broke
you're not going out to eat you're in
debt you're broke you work all the time
you're in debt you're broke there's a
great place to go when you're broke to
work okay this is what you do and you
bust your butt and it scorched Earth no
lifestyle no nothing you sell so much
stuff the kids think they're next you
name the dog eBay and the cat Craigslist
everything's going out the door we're
getting this mess cleaned up we're sick
and tired of being sick and tired people
that do it with that intensity get out
of debt in an average of about 18 to 24
months now average means that some of
you have half a million dollars of
student loan debt like Jay did took her
seven years okay and then average means
some of you have five thousand dollars
in debt and ten thousand dollars in your
bank account when you heard me rent and
you just went and paid it off now you're
debt free took you 13 seconds okay but
the average is 18 to 24 months then when
you finish that with the same level of
intensity you continue we call this
gazelle intensity the gazelle running
from the cheetah for its life
when you get out of debt you finish baby
step three with the gazelle intensity
and that's three to six months of
expenses then we turn off the intensity
and we move from intensity to
intentionality and we do baby steps four
five and six simultaneously that's
fifteen percent of your income going
into retirement that's what's going to
make you a baby steps millionaire in
about 12 years following this plan
you're gonna put money into kids college
if that's applicable and you didn't sell
them off
number baby step six is any other money
we can find in the budget we're going to
throw at the house and the average
person paying off their house following
these baby steps is doing it we've been
doing this for 30 years is doing it in
about 10 in about 10.2 years and our
baby steps millionaires study we did of
millionaires some of them have followed
our stuff some of them hadn't they were
doing it in about 11 years wow so but
the point is there's an intensity for
that first three steps to get out of
debt and get your emergency fund in
place because until you do that you're
broke
and you're walking around in a culture
strutting around like you've got some
money you got no money shut up you're
broke
quit acting like you're something you're
and it's putting on the crap has got to
stop and Jade you've been hearing this
thing in baby step two where people are
struggling with motivation yeah you know
I get it all the time Dave they go in my
in my DMs direct message even in our
Financial Peace University class I get
the same question which is Jade you guys
did this for seven and a half to eight
years how do you stay motivated
and you know at first Dave I would kind
of give like like the nice answer like
well you gotta you gotta connect to your
why and and all of this and I really got
to thinking about it I was talking to
Sam about it and the more people ask me
it kind of frustrates me because there's
gotta be no other option y'all don't get
Jade frustrated okay there's kind of an
idea when Sam and I were getting out of
debt there was no option to not do it
it it's a must I have to my life will
never be what I need it to be what it
should be what God wants it to be if I
don't do this so so this idea that well
maybe I'll do it and maybe I won't that
cannot exist it's not an intellectual
exercise it's not an exercise you've got
it it's an emotional visceral decision
yes I I must It's gotta and nobody
for you you know you listen to this show
or you come to a live event and we'll
light that match for you but you've
gotta like stoke your own flame my buddy
uh Lucas did a talk about this he said
um you could be a spark or you can be a
flame
and you can tell the difference by when
the wind blows if you're a spark the
wind blows immediately you go out just
like that but if you're a flame when the
wind blows you get you get bigger you
get more aggressive you get larger and
more Fierce and and if you're talking to
me and you're asking me how can I stay
more motivated I'm sorry to tell you
you're a spark
you're just you're just a little
fluttering spark and you've got to do
what it takes you just called you people
names she called you a little spark
you're just a little Sparkle wimpy spark
and the moment the wind blows man the
minute you have to dip into your
emergency fund the minute something
happens you're ready to go well I don't
know if I want to do it I don't know if
it's worth it try that Ramsey stuff it
doesn't work what do you mean what do
you mean you don't know if it's worth it
to you do you want to change your life
or not
it's that simple motivate if you're
waiting to feel motivated you will be
waiting forever because that is
completely mythological motivation is
not an external
substance no it doesn't come from out
there to take you in here yeah and you
know one of the things I I've kind of
run into this over the years of me
teaching it too the same frustration
Blake uh Thompson our old producer he
now runs all of Ramsay networks yeah he
used to do these comedy bits and he
created this comedy bit that we would
play on the air called detenol
and it was a pill you could take that
would get you out of debt if you just
took this pill you'd be out of debt and
that's what everybody's looking for
they're looking for a magic pill you
know I was wandering in the vitamin
aisle and I ran into my one of my pastor
friends who's kind of loud and he yells
down the aisle Ramsay there's no pill on
there's going to help you you got to eat
less
so good it's so true you all want the
magic pill that's gonna magically make
this easy it ain't gonna be easy it
doesn't exist let me tell you what easy
is easy is when you finish
easiest when you finish it gets easier
but let me tell you this I mean there's
other side of that where people go man
this is hard right paying off that's
hard to do working as hard you wish
learn to do hard but can I just say it's
also what is also hard is not being able
to afford groceries man that's hard
that's hard when you look up and you
don't have the money to take care of
your kids you don't have the money to
spin the gas to go visit a loved one in
the hospital I'm talking about myself
that that was hard that's hard to
stomach because that reflects back on
you and you go oh my god I've been an
idiot with money
and in comparison just saying in
comparison it's easier to sacrifice to
win so that you don't have to endure
those other things you live like no one
else so that lighter later and live and
give like no one else and just no
discipline seems Pleasant at the time
the Bible says but it yields a harvest
of righteousness yeah listen you're
going to pay a price you're going to pay
a price you're either going to pay a
price of mediocrity throughout the whole
scope of your life and your life's gonna
suck perpetually yeah because the time's
going to pass regardless we're still
waiting on the government to fix your
life that's humorous and you know so
you're either going to live a life of
mediocrity because you half butt do
stuff or you're going to pay a price for
a short period of time and you're going
to like yourself on fire and be a flame
not a spark I love that that's a good
line I like this and a lot of you are
going to look up you know Dave said the
stats on getting through baby step two
most people who get through baby step
one through three it's two and a half to
three years that sounds a lot like a lot
when you just say it but man that is
just a drop in the Bucket over time and
some of you who've been kicking your
student loan can down the road for three
years you could have been done and
finished you could have been done and
let me tell you something you just wish
when this thing kicks back up you are
going to regret it start today yeah
start today so where does it come from
it comes in believing the best way to
live your life is free and it's worth
paying the price to get there that'll
give you the motivation sure we want to
change my family tree I want to look at
my kids eyes and have a different set of
values a Godly Man leaves an inheritance
to his children's children amen
[Music]
[Applause]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
producer here on the Ramsey show has a
boss his boss is named Blake Thompson he
likes to brown nose his boss and so he
dug up the old detonal clip during the
commercial break and so we'll um you
know the the Death and All if you didn't
catch it uh it is the the only way that
you can get out of debt by taking a pill
all right here we go
nationally syndicated talk radio host
Dave Ramsey has often said that there is
no magic pill for getting out of debt
well sorry Mr Ramsey but there is and
it's called Dental is a 100 all-natural
drug that is guaranteed to control your
spending and control your desire to
overspend one pill a day and you will no
longer feel the need to spend money you
don't have we have created this drug
because we care about you detonal the
pill that cares minor side effects may
include fatigue
headache my head nervousness sore throat
explosive diarrhea insomnia I can't
sleep drowsiness I can't stay away
horrible nightmares oh gastronomical
trauma oh my hallucinations that rabbit
just said my name chronic halitosis whoa
a slight cough and a runny nose dentinol
brought to you by the credit card
Association of America credit the easy
way out
oh wow this show has changed a lot I
mean that's a 20 year old bit not bad
it's still funny not bad I found it to
be funny he did some others that would
get you canceled now oh that one that
one's passable though all right here we
go Jade Washoe Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Omar
and Angela are with us hey guys how are
you hi doing well doing well how are you
better than we deserve where do you guys
live up the street in Nashville
Tennessee
welcome neighbor good to have you and
how much data have you guys paid off we
paid off a 175 540 and 61 cents
phenomenal how long did this take 20
months whoa and your range of income
during that time during that time it
went from 158 000 to 245 000. wow wow in
20 months somebody get a job
that would be that would be Angela okay
excellent what do you guys do for a
living I'm an in-house attorney for a
wealth management firm and I'm a project
manager for Consulting wow both of you
are killing it what great income yeah so
what kind of debt was this 176
000 oh law school there was some law
school debt there was some grad schools
two grad schools law school and a couple
credit cards and uh balance on a car
okay very cool all right so tell us your
story how did you get started on this
Ramsay stuff and why 20 months ago
so we've been married now for two years
and uh there will be three months
actually as of four days ago and this
journey started actually when we got
engaged in November of 2019.
um little did we know how much the world
would change a couple months later but
um for me personally nothing will have
you take a really deep look into your
life and your finances and in fact every
other aspect of your life until you
decide you're going to get married and
so I took a deep dive into my finances
took a strong look at sort of what I had
left and thankfully my brother had taken
FPU my dad has hosted two sessions at
his church down in Florida so I was
pretty familiar with you Dave and what I
decided to do was to take your steps on
a test run with my personal finances
before we got married and in about eight
months I paid off about 75 percent of
the debt that I had before we got
married it works it absolutely worked uh
got on the budgeting app you worked yeah
it absolutely worked and so before we
got married we had a deep you know one
of several deep Financial talks and let
her know that this is a path I really
wanted us to go on and she tepidly
accepted
Angela how did that change how did you
what was that Journey like to get on
board with that yeah so marrying a crazy
man so I mean we got married December
4th 2020 and that same month we started
our budget you know to aggressively pay
off our debt and initially I was you
know in a transition of my career I was
going to make more money so I'm like are
we really gonna like start tightening
you know our belts and so it was once I
started seeing those balances go down
and I was like oh okay we would have
these like check-ins with each other and
he's like this is how much we paid in
the last couple months I'm like
oh okay you know so that was motivating
that debt snowball of just seeing the
debt go away and as our income grew
thinking about like what we could do for
ourselves for our family for our future
you know so just seeing that debt go
down just really motivated me so the
psychology aspect of the debt snowball
really does work oh yeah it really does
yeah every month with me just checked in
I was like oh my gosh I can't believe
you did that yeah pretty amazing yeah so
you get married
right off the back end of the coveted
mesh well the beginnings that depends on
who you are and where the back some
people are still in it but yeah
um but yeah but I mean December after
the world shut down in March April right
and so uh wow what a time and and then
in the midst of that you're still paying
off all this debt you 75 000 you knocked
out Omar I mean that's pretty incredible
then you get married and and then it's
game on and you start to see the results
and just turned up the heat even more
absolutely absolutely I mean in some
ways covid was a mixed blessing because
I had nothing to do so it was very easy
to budget in my entertainment budget was
a close to zero is a zero close to zero
as you could possibly get it so eating
out the eating out thing was not a
problem there was no place to go not at
all not at all let's become a good cook
and you took advantage of the student
loan pause I'm guessing oh absolutely I
mean it was the only I mean it was real
it was tangible and it just made that
balance just go down so much faster and
it was motivating to say the least very
cool say something to the people who are
waiting say something to the folks who
are like hey I'm taking advantage of the
you know no payments I can put that back
in my you know spend it on something
else talk to those folks for a minute I
want to say I'm very grateful first and
foremost that I took advantage of that
period of time because we saved
thousands upon thousands in interest and
I think uh if I did my math correctly a
lot of student loan servicers aren't
collecting until October so you have
months to go you could still make a huge
dent make a lot of progress because um
you know the the nerdy law student in me
we I listened to the arguments of the
Supreme Court just last week and uh it's
not looking good and I'm thankful that
we made decisions that whatever happens
up in Washington up on those Court steps
doesn't really affect us there you go
they're not in control of my life now so
true so true you guys are a power couple
man
I mean I feel it through the glass it's
great all right so now your brother
taught Financial Peace University your
dad did it a couple of times with the
church back in Florida she kind of knew
it was hovering out there but now you
walked in it both of you yes have
experienced this as a married couple
tell folks if they want to pay off a
hundred and seventy six thousand dollars
in 20 months what is the secret to
getting out of debt well I'm sure we'd
definitely have opinions my personal one
is you have to tell your money where to
go I still use the every dollar app to
this day because we still have goals
moving forward and um it's if you don't
have control of your money your money's
going to take control of you yeah and
you have to stay focused and you can't
get distracted you know there were so
many times where we'd be like oh we
could do this or that or someone has
some other advice and was like nope this
is what we're gonna do until that
balance is zero we're not doing anything
else so you just have to stay focused
don't pay attention to any of those
distractions
it was sacrificed wasn't it yeah it was
hard wasn't it yeah yeah was it worth it
it was so worth it absolutely so worth
it will you go back in debt oh no never
again absolutely
tricks are for kids yeah way to go you
guys y'all are you're amazing you're
very very proud of you who's your
biggest cheerleaders I bet dad and
brother oh yeah they were very good her
parents were wonderful
um and then we have our friends
Charlotte's here and Jeff um they
actually uh started FPU on their
honeymoon way to go oh that's romantic
not okay yeah
cool well way to go guys that was very
fun very fun hey we've got the live and
give bundle for you the uh baby steps
millionaires book which you're probably
there are about to be there soon at the
way you're going with this income and
this this level of focus excellently uh
Total Money Makeover book for you to
give away Financial Peace University
membership for you to give away so you
can live some of it you can give some of
it that's why we call it the live and
give bundle proud of you guys thank you
well done well done Your Heroes Omar and
Angela Nashville 176 thousand dollars
paid off in 20 months making 158 to 245.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream all right three two one we're
debt free
yeah
176 thousand dollars we're approaching
five million dollars already paid off on
debt free screams and it's still early
in the year that's for this year alone
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today a lot of
you got questions about taxes one of our
listeners wrote this in uh Dave I gave a
car to a family in my town and I'm
worried how that affects my taxes and
their taxes I don't want either of us to
pay penalties or some crazy fees uh well
good for you
generosity I like that sounds like
you're living and giving like no one
else for 2022
if you give gifts worth sixteen thousand
dollars or less
individual to individual you can do that
without paying any taxes the amount goes
up to 17 000 in 2023. the lifetime gift
limit is 12 million that's your estate
tax exemption amount
and uh the person you gave the gift to
doesn't have to pay the gift tax but if
the value is more than sixteen thousand
the gift tax on the amount above 16 000
would be 18 to 40 percent of the gifts
value and although some gifts are tax
exempt that's not the case here so
here's the thing
I'm gonna bet good money that that car
that you gave away was not over sixteen
thousand dollars so you got no gift tax
don't worry about it you don't have to
file anything they don't have to file
anything an individual can give an
individual without filing a thing up to
sixteen thousand dollars last year
well I gave him thirty two thousand okay
well then write a letter and have them
sign it if you are married
or if they are married this says you
gave half a car
to the wife and half a car to the
husband
and have them sign that that is the
agreement you're still under 16 000 per
individual moms and dads that want to
give grown kids money because you've got
too much money you don't know what to do
with it you could actually give
sixty four thousand dollars so Mom gives
daughter-in-law 16 and Son 16 Dad gives
daughter-in-law 16 and daughter and son
16. four different checks all sixteen
thousand you're still under sixteen
thousand individual to individual and
that is not married couples are not
individuals uh and when it comes are
there a couple is not a unit it's two
people in there still in terms of the
way the tax law looks at it so best
thing you can do is work with a tax Pro
that's up to date on the latest tax code
head to ramseysolutions.com
taxpro we'll get you connected with uh
someone who's Ramsey trusted to do your
taxes if you have a complicated return
and Check Smart tax at
ramseysolutions.com if you don't have a
complicated return and we'll help you
with a very easy piece of software very
inexpensive to file your taxes you gotta
love it Matthew's in Columbus Ohio hey
Matthew welcome to the Ramsay show
thanks how are you better than I deserve
what's up in your world
yeah so uh I just switched uh rolls to
another organization that is a state-run
agency and so 10 of my paycheck
automatically goes to the state
retirement fund
and then uh so I was wondering if I have
an option to do a 403b or a 457b both
pre-tax or Ross should I put the five
percent in one or both of those funds
should I put them in just a Roth I would
put it in an individual Roth IRA
okay get a broker go to
ramseysolutions.com click on Smart
investor and just do you an individual
Roth uh because you got more control and
more options than the 403b if you don't
do that do the 403 b 457 is just a third
comp
that's a different program
and so yeah and the the 10 is mandatory
I take it in your state
yes do you have any control on what it's
invested in
um I can do so there's three options on
that side I can do an alternative where
I can put them into I can put them into
the funds that I want per se I mean they
still have selected funds
or a traditional pension or a deferred
contribution which I think I also get to
select from a variety of things hey you
picked a not b or c you pick the mutual
funds
okay and what you're looking for we
suggest you spray it across four types
yeah growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international is what you're
looking for 25 into each one now when
are you vested in the state when do you
have that as your own that you own it if
you left you could roll it
if I if I go to a i it's automatic and
they match uh they give us a
um it's supposed to be a 14 match if I
went with BRC but because of the
agreement with the state retirement fund
company
um I get only like 11 so it's you know
it's 10 plus 11 that would be added to
my uh fund perfect do I
that way that way you own it and you
control it that increases your chances
of your probability of becoming wealthy
far beyond some State managed crap
okay hey well done man very good good
call good question thank you for joining
us open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five times in Toledo
hey Tom what's up
how you doing sir better than we deserve
how can we help
very good hey uh I'm 60 almost 61 years
old I've been working all my life my
wife and I we are debt free except our
house way to go um has been that way for
quite a while uh whatever God gives us
we're trying to be good stewards but my
question is this I retired in 09 I've
been double dipping I went back to work
for the state I've got about
um it looks like it's going to be about
000 come to maturity when I turned 65 a
money market account uh because of the
state retirement
um I owe about a hundred and fifty
thousand on our house uh we want to get
it paid down to about 110 before I
retire in 65. what would I do with that
250 when I pay off the house
or what what would you suggest
aside from that money market account
what's your net worth right now
uh we've got oh
I've got about 60 uh ninety thousand
dollars in a reserve fund and then we've
got our emergency fund of four months
we've got a slush fund a god fund a
Utility Fund so I would say right now uh
we we would be at uh and then like in
your retirement funds probably at 300 to
350 000. okay how much is in the slush
fund
the slush bond is
um right now six thousand dollars we
have about sixteen hundred dollars of
discretionary funds monthly
um that's why I said we're going to be
putting five to a thousand dollars extra
a month against the house yeah when do
you uh what what is the the money is it
truly a money market account you don't
have it invested in mutual funds
well that's what they call it that's
what opiers calls it since I retired
once already I can't have a second
retirement with them so I know can you
not have it invested better than a money
market account because a money market
account is paying you one percent right
yeah no I can't I can't do it I can't
pull that money and I mean inside they
don't offer other investment options
it's still stuck at the state right it's
still stuck at the state right
yes okay do they not have other options
other than just a money market that you
can move it to inside the state program
no
that's weird you have the third comp but
that is above and beyond my contribution
the my contributions ten percent and my
employer's contribution is 14 just like
the last guy we talked to yeah and so
the the but the question is usually they
have more than one option that you can
have it parked in and to say it only has
to be in Money Market is highly crazy
like I think you're wrong it's that
unusual okay I want you to see if you
can get that invested better into some
good mutual funds poke around see if
they have other options while it sits
there too because you got five more
years right
right okay let's do that and then let's
take a bunch of that 90 000 and a bunch
of your great income now let's pay off
your house in about a year yeah
okay like 61 let's have it paid for
you throw that big 90 000 account that's
sitting there at it you only owe 150
that's 60 Grand you got a slush fund you
scratch together some of the Nickels out
of the couch you start throwing your
income out of your uh budget at it and
let's get that thing knocked out one
percent on a money Mark he could have
put it in a high yield savings account
and done better than that they don't
have I mean it's stuck in a retirement
program yeah that doesn't some
retirement programs state run are dumber
than a rock
you never know so I don't know what they
got I don't know what the deal is but
even the stupid ones have more than one
option usually so I'd look at it I
really would and but let's just try to
take that 90 and half the house yeah
that's the thing this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
guys it's Jay if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay way just go
to ramseysolutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five you call
we'll talk about your life and your
money Justin's with us in Colorado
Springs hey Justin welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey Dave hey Jade my two favorite hosts
how are you better than we deserve how
can we help yes I'm sure you guys don't
remember me but I called in about a
month ago and I thought it was going to
be a bad YouTube segment didn't end up
being too bad oh yeah I think I remember
tell me more
yeah so uh we uh we had the only debt we
had with a you know a truck and
um I was had some questions about
investing long term and you guys laid
out a really good plan for me and I'm
kind of here just to give you a little
update
favorite
yeah so I didn't follow your plan to a T
and hence why I'm calling
and so we uh we had a third and we had
about I thought we had about a thirty
thousand dollar
uh truck room we actually had about 37
but you guys recommended we pull it from
our savings and pay it off and we didn't
pay it off that day but we did pay it
off on in three weeks so 37 000 in three
weeks so I wanted to let you know it was
a very successful call we followed you
guys as tips and now we are officially
debt free and uh yes and with that um I
did quick math on it at the 650 monthly
contributions we were doing
um on our truck and insurance
um on a rate of return of 10 average
after 20 years that's 500 000 and 30
years that's over one million wonderful
yeah so and my question today and I once
again I hope you guys take it easy on me
with this we did free up the cash and we
did Max out the 15
of our uh 401ks and we do have an extra
good chunk of money going to the house
and do you have your uh three to six
months emergency fund
and the last show that uh Dave you
recommended I follow up on my 529 it is
in a mutual account and there's
currently fifteen thousand dollars in
there okay good and
um and now my question is we I do have a
little bit more freedom money and I know
I know I think the answer to this I used
to dabble a little bit in the day
trading should I play around with that
or just leave it alone
you uh you know the answer you know the
answer to that I mean okay the study the
studies tell us 78 of the day Traders
lose money
okay so it's not as bad as buying a
lottery ticket but it's close
okay
yeah I uh about years ago when I was
actually worked in the financial
industry I used to do a little trading
and I did okay but I know the market is
a little bit different today you know
the other study that's very interesting
on day trading is this day Traders are a
lot like fishermen
they remember the days they caught stuff
and they have a mental block on the days
they didn't okay yeah and they go yeah
the fishing's pretty good over there you
usually catch something and you really
don't but you just remember the days you
caught fish you know and so it actually
is weird you you probably didn't but you
block it out because it's like this is
fun and I'm good at it and no you're
really not you're suck and so don't do
it you know and I I don't do it and I
know a lot about it I don't fool with it
uh I would rather you get your house
paid off and if you want to trade in
something save up a pile of money and
buy you a piece of Real Estate
okay you got a lot better chance of
making some money
uh buying a piece of real estate selling
it you know that kind of stuff then you
do with cash no debt than you do after
your house is paid off then you do
messing around day trading but
um I mean day trading is
it's just again I I don't care what
people do you can do whatever you want
to do yeah but what I'm always looking
for for me and I'm not going to tell you
guys to do something out there that I
wouldn't do personally yeah I'm looking
for something that has a high
probability of success and so I don't
really care what your broke
brother-in-law's opinion is
and so that's why I didn't buy crypto
and now I look like a freaking genius
and I didn't buy Bernie Madoff and now I
look like a freaking genius you know and
I didn't uh and you know I don't try to
make my money at the craps table in
Vegas and now I look like a freaking
genius and I don't buy lottery tickets
and now I look like a freaking genius
and so all I do is figure whatever broke
people are doing and their suggestions
are I tried to not do that and then you
look like a freaking genius you know and
so uh that's how this thing works and
then you find out what rich people are
doing and you know the number of
millionaires that we studied out of ten
thousand one hundred sixty seven that
made their million dollars or a greater
net worth that we studied in doing day
trading
precisely zero
about as many as made it using airline
miles with their credit card yeah wealth
gained hastily will dwindle
we know that and my guy you know if
you're if you're chasing after that
chances are you're trying to get rich
quick I mean let's just say it like that
I mean that's a good point here's the
thing you got to remember okay there's
gambling I'm making fun of it okay
there's gambling and that's real
gambling okay that's like we're playing
cards we're playing the roulette wheel
we're playing craps okay real game are
betting on a sports team whatever that's
real gambling all right then there is
speculating which is where I'm trying to
make a short term
gain and it's usually a high gain right
and then there's investing and investing
is always over a long period of time
investing is always the tortoise
where speculating is the hair
and I don't know gambling your drunk
brother-in-law I don't know whatever it
is I don't know but it's um but you know
what I'm saying tortoise the tortoises
who we find when we study wealthy people
we always find tortoises yeah I'm fine
with being a tortoise you know anytime
I've ever posted about this you know
about your rate of return and this and
that and people are always saying Jade
you can't get a 10 rate of return where
can I find that and I realize you're not
500 you're not alone but they're not
long-term thinkers because they're
thinking how can I get a 10 return this
year or right now or this week this week
and I'm like that's not how it works
you've got to be invested over time
you've got to be in this thing for the
Long Haul it's it's a habit and a muscle
that you're building over time allowing
that compound interest to grow for you
so yeah you know different mindset it's
just
I'm the guy that always I wanted I
always thought I was smarter than the
average bear and I could figure it out
and I could find a way to do the
shortcut yeah and my wife every time I
bring it up something even sounds like
that she goes you're scheming and
scamming
yeah you're scheming and scamming you're
trying to hide the P under a shell just
do the SMART stuff quit trying to be
quit trying to beat the system yeah you
know it's like well I mean that you're
the one the ones that I always I love if
you read our comments people ripping on
us yeah it's like well Rams is advice is
good if you want to be middle class
except for those millions of
millionaires that we made but other than
that yeah that's so funny because
because this is somebody who's trying to
speculate yeah and get rich quick and
get rich easy and it just best way to
get rich quick is get rich slow well and
everybody thinks that they've come up
with a new new and improved way yeah
right there's theirs is the new Surefire
way yeah I mean like nothing down real
estate's new it's like it's blown up
like it's never happened before because
it's on Tic Tac that's what made it that
way I mean it's not it's new it's not
new I was doing nothing down real estate
in 1982 before you or any of you out
there were a sparkle on your mama's eye
I mean seriously unbelievable
wow it's not new there's there's just
new versions of stupid that's right new
versions
there's nothing new Under the Sun wow
still stupid stuff good question sir
thanks for following up this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
they're one
they're watching guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
up to 50 percent off everything
site-wide visit blinds.com today to
learn more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
Jade washout Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at AAA
825-5225 with debt payments and now
inflation stealing more and more of your
paycheck and we know a lot of folks out
there are just um
scared
and I understand I've been there it's
not fun
um but you're going to stay right where
you are if you stay right where you are
boy that was deep
um I mean seriously you shouldn't have
to live with that kind of stress
you want things to change
you've got to say I've had it I'm not
living like this anymore I've had it
and do something new with your money
we'll show you what to do if you want to
learn how to handle money we can show
you we've taught more people than
anybody else 10 million people have been
through Financial Peace University
it's our nine lesson course you hear
people talk about when they're doing
their debt free screens it'll teach you
how to get out of debt become wealthy
and outrageously generous the right way
the fastest
right way
it's everything you wish you'd learned
about on how to handle money
so decide you're done I'm tired of being
scared
tired of being stressed
and you start Financial Peace University
at ramseysolutions.com fpur
ramseysolutions.com
FPU Joey's in Boise hi Joey welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey Dave thanks for having me sure
what's up Phil
um fiance and I are getting married in
about three months
um we are looking to buy a house uh I
currently own a house on a duplex I'll
run out one side live on the other side
the amount that I make towards the
mortgage is about eight hundred dollars
it's two bed one bath on my side uh
we're looking at having kids pretty
quickly on so she kind of wants
something bigger she doesn't want to
move into my place so we're looking for
a three bed two bath but with the
housing market what's done since I
bought my place and then the uh interest
rates are estimated monthly note would
be about 3 600 a month so
she's very anti-death and anti-debt even
less than her she's really making a push
for it I'd rather stay in my place until
we have to upsize
um I mean just looking for advice
what's your duplex work worth right now
about a half a million wow are you
talking about selling it to do this deal
um I'd rather not sell it um I'd rather
not have a 3 600 payment I know that's
right
well the the payment on this duplex is
two thousand dollars no you missed the
point yes yes yeah the problem the
reason you have a 3600 payments you're
trying to keep the duplex
do you think it's a better idea to sell
the duplex and and look for you should
not buy another house unless you do
so you only have two possible decisions
one sell the duplex and buy a house
two live in a duplex with an angry new
wife
whoo
better to live on the corner of a roof
than being with a
name yes
oh Lord you don't want that trust me
you don't think there's marry me trying
to talk her into
uh to move it into here giving that
another try she said she doesn't want to
do it
do you really think that's smart really
I mean seriously
from a relational standpoint
I mean it's not a bad place I get where
she's coming from though it's not our
own place and that's it's a bachelor pad
she's not moving in dude she wants a
fresh start she wants a place we want
some place that doesn't have those
smells
sell your duplex get your property and
get your property where your payment is
no more than a fourth of your take-home
pay household income on a fourth of your
take-home pay 15-year fix 15-year fixed
no more than that and if that's not 30
just forget then that then don't buy a
house then don't buy a house what are
you wait a minute where what are you
pricing out because you're going to sell
what will you take home after you sell
this duplex how much heck what have you
got
140 000 in equity okay what's your
household income what's your income
what's your income
our combined incomes are going to be
about 130.
okay and um listen I've been divorcedure
you're looking in the wrong neighborhood
so
okay you can find a house that's not the
duplex and that is within your budget
you know you're trying to set up a thing
where the only thing is smart staying in
the duplex and I got to tell you man
um it's she's not gonna do it it's not
it's not gonna work I mean you know she
might do it for a short period of time
but you're gonna wish she didn't before
it's over just don't do this it's not I
mean but you're trying to make this
somehow just a financial decision what
you got to remember is personal finance
involves relationships personal finance
involves your life where your kids live
your dogs live your wife lives all this
kind of stuff I mean and and you don't
get to just get a pass on math because
she wants a new house math is still math
or because you want or because you don't
want a new house and now you're trying
to justify there's no houses in Boise
that we can all bullcrap
seriously I mean Boise's had a big bump
in price I know that because California
invaded it sure you know they were
running out of that state like their
hair was on fire and Boise was close so
um no question about it that happened
right but the um we know we've seen that
we've seen the numbers the you know the
the flea from California and so I
and so um yeah it happened though yeah
don't you're you're Joey your the
rationalization is dripping all over
this conversation to where you try to
guide the conversation the way where you
want it to land and it's just not going
to work here yeah okay we're not going
to do that I think you guys need to have
a few more conversations about
what you both want and what that looks
like not just not just financially but
just what does our life look like and it
sounds like she doesn't want to live in
a duplex next to duplex neighbors and
she doesn't want to live in his whole
place yeah and that's not I mean I don't
blame her hey guys listen that's a good
point okay there's a
even if it was nice yeah here's what
happens I gotta tell you statistically
this would be I'm making this number up
but I'm not gonna be far off north of 80
of the time
young dude goes and buys even a nice
house not a duplex not something not not
a crummy smelly bachelor pad nothing I
mean just a nice place
okay
and then when he gets married later he
discovers he bought the wrong house yep
like 80 of the time because he didn't
have her to tell him it was the wrong
house and so it was the wrong house and
so even if it was the right house it's
now the wrong house and so you are
moving so if you buy a house dude out
there dudes you're 25 you're 24 and then
you meet her yeah a few months later and
you get married a year later you're
going to discover you bought the wrong
house oh I'm laughing because that's
what happened with Sam and I you did it
too he did it he had a house with his uh
Little Town House Sam and he did and was
with his mom you know him and his mom
went on it together oh they were doing a
mom investment yeah in 2008 no longer an
investment
and uh well no I'm saying we had to sell
it in 2008
timing but
you bought and had girlfriends and went
with your mom I don't want to live up in
there I need something fresh I need I
need a fresh house and fresh Furniture
I'm the fresh wife
that I knew it was coming I'd seen that
you just personified it for me thank you
that's perfect that's perfect very well
done yeah Joey uh you see you know
now you got Jade going so now now you
ain't got a chance dude so yeah we're
all on your wife's side
fresh we need fresh no remnants no no
remnants of the former life yes I don't
want to see it who because I'm looking
I'm saying who picked out that one no
I don't want to know that I don't
want who bought that lamp I don't want
to know I don't want to know that no
yeah I'm turning I just turned that lamb
on I got I got yeah I got I got the
Willies I don't know who's been up in
here and I don't want to know
that's fabulous I love it even if it's
not that it's just you it's not yours
you didn't pick it that's right if
everything else was okay and it's fun to
do that I mean let's be honest he's
never had a date in his life and there
won't win any of that it's still you
didn't pick it yeah it's fun to go
for a place in in shop with your
like enjoy that
I can do together and bring you closer
together learn about each other fresh or
fresh gotta love it this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
Jade Washington Ramsey personality is my
co-host today when I started on the
radio about 31 years ago it was much to
my surprise after about a year that we
had a bunch of listeners and then my
second surprise was that people actually
wanted me to say nice things about their
company and they would pay me to do that
called endorsements
and Churchill Mortgage came on that year
Churchill Mortgage has been with me now
for um 30 years on the air
the number of times a
a host of any kind a a show of any kind
can say they have endorsed a single
company for 31 years is almost zero
either the company goes sideways the
host goes sideways or becomes irrelevant
gets thrown off or whatever but I've
managed to stay on and they've managed
to keep taking care of their customers
and we've managed to keep saying go to
Churchill Mortgage for 31 years and but
soon after that we started having people
come to us and they wanted us to endorse
them and it was like
and I actually took on one you know in
the early days we were trying to make a
living and I actually took on a thing
and and then one of my I ran into one of
my friends he goes hey do you really do
that would you really tell me to do that
and I had to go uh
no I just I just didn't know
and I felt ashamed you know yeah because
I had done that and then so we developed
a rule like at you know 29 years ago or
whatever it was around here that we
don't endorse we don't put anything on
the air oh and we especially don't put
one of our voices on it saying go do
this uh unless we would send our best
friend there our little sister there or
whatever your mama there right and so if
we that's a smell test we use around
here and so all that to say you know
we're thrilled to endorse sander
insurance and Churchill Mortgage and
thrilled to had PODS moving and storage
as our uh as our studio sponsor and to
tell people to use them to move
and today we've got a new sponsor
joining us on the question of the day
that we do each day the new sponsor is
neighborly
and uh they are uh they're the sponsor
and and they've got all kinds of
different companies out there that are
the neighborly companies like you've
heard of like Mr Root or or you've heard
of Mr Handyman or Mr Electric we
actually endorse Mr Electric individual
franchisees in some markets and
individual cities that I've I've voiced
the ads for for a local radio station
that kind of a thing so neighborly has
got a a whole bunch of different
Services
uh from Five Star painting to Molly Maid
most people have heard of Molly Maid oh
yeah uh mosquito Joe uh again Mr
Electric Mr Handyman Mr Root or Mr
Rooter is a very very popular big big
brand and they've got a bunch of these
things Precision Overhead Garage Door
Service uh that they have as franchisees
they're the franchise or and so
neighborly is a company we've checked
out and uh they use Smart dollar they
use our stuff to teach their teams
that's great about money and we feel
really good about the company neighborly
we feel good about the the types of
services that they provide and we're
honored to have them as a new
endorsement here on the Ramsey Show new
trusted member of the Ramsey Show and
they are our neighborly question of the
day sponsor our question today is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services when you need to make
repairs schedule routine maintenance or
find local help for Home Improvement
projects neighborly is your source for
Reliable home service providers in your
area go to neighborly.com to start your
search today's question comes from Ruth
in Virginia my debit card has fraud has
had fraud two times in a two-week period
it's time consuming to change all the
auto payments and to get a new card some
people say that credit cards are harder
for thieves to do fraud than on a debit
card what is your experience and opinion
with this is there any truth to that
theory also some people recommend using
a credit card for all purchases and
paying it off at the end of the month I
know that you would advise against doing
that method can you shed some light onto
why this is an unwise method
happy to I love that you called it a
theory because that's honestly what it
is I'm going to be honest with you you
asked for my opinion and my experience I
have never ever had problems with using
a debit card and I have experienced much
fraud
um you know there's been plenty of times
where I saw the guy I saw the
transactions from Best Buy popping up uh
on my screen as it was happening around
Christmas time and I just called the
bank and I said someone's got my
information this is a fraud fraudulent
purchase I mean lickety split the money
was back in my account and you can look
and I was just talking with Dave about
this you know I think a lot of people
get hung up because if you look at some
of these acts the electronic funds
transfer act you know and and some of
these things it'll say there's some
slight differences but at the end of the
day the actual contract on your
MasterCard right on that that trumps
that and it's zero liability it's the
same if you look up MasterCard and visa
and look at the actual agreement online
for it says for embed cards and credit
cards
you have the exact same fraud protection
you have zero liability zero zero now if
your debit card in a two-week period
has you had fraud two times your credit
card would have had fraud two times
because wherever you're using that thing
is being picked up somewhere
it's your information no and if I get
your credit card information you're
gonna have to change your credit card
same thing you're going to get the same
phone call from the same bank and
they're going to say we have activity
that does not look like it is your
normal activity and we're going to stop
all charges until we verify this you get
that from debit cards you get that from
credit cards with my bank it's an
automated thing they call up and I have
to push one and I have to push about
three things and I verify that verify
that verify that so you know I was down
in Mexico Cabo a few weeks ago and
they're like what are you doing in
Mexico you're a hillbilly and I'm like
so they should you know we're charged
we're charged we're charged and I'm like
no not wear charge it was me I'm here
and so yeah but that's that the
algorithms follow the pattern of the
purchases for a debit card or a credit
card because here's the thing
in either case
credit card or debit card you are not
liable for a transaction that was not
yours if you have a Visa or a MasterCard
product that is their agreement with you
period
so in either case if Best Buy or I don't
know whatever place in Taco Bar Mexico
right uh is showing up that means
somebody got your number and it wasn't
you in this case it was me in your case
it wasn't you but if they if they let
that money go yeah the bank lets that
money go out of your account if it's a
debit card or just against your credit
card they can't get it back they lose
money that's right so in in and they
lose the exact the same money on a
credit card fraud as they lose on a
debit card fraud and so they run the
same theft and fraud algorithms to track
to see if you're doing it's no different
it's no different so if you don't like
having to change everything and get a
new card with all your auto payments uh
with a debit card you're gonna have the
exact same thing happen with your credit
card it has nothing to do with debit or
credit has to do with where you're using
the stupid thing right you're running
somewhere where somebody's picking the
thing up
and you need to look at your somewhere
you're going where somebody's got a
fraud reader or something a card reader
that's a stuck in the thing and uh or
your passwords suck something somebody's
getting your information I know some of
the guys around here they like
privacy.com because you can buy things
online and you can basically use uh
Incognito card so they're never seeing
your information so that's an option for
people who are looking but I like the
and I kind of want to address Dave the
the second part of this question which
is saying some people recommend and I
this is again this is the thing that
everybody is doing and since everybody's
doing it
don't do it which is I put all my
purchases for the month on my credit
card just to make it easy Dave so I
don't have to think about it you know I
just go to the score store swipe it and
then at the end of the month I can just
pay it off when my check comes in I put
all my purchases on my debit card and
comes out my checking account
what's the difference well one day oh I
just used my money that's all
you're going to use your money to pay it
off yeah it's Dumber though you have to
have your brain turned on it's
absolutely dumber than a rock
you don't want to have your brain turned
on you want to just be able to swipe it
and not think about it
I don't want to think about my money and
I want to have some but yeah magically
moronic yet magically you'll have just
enough from your paycheck to pay it off
that well we know that's wrong let me
help you with this we know that's not
the case people who don't think about
money don't have any that's how this
works a trillion dollars Dave of credit
card debt that's what we're at yeah
we're new record new record in card debt
too and the default rate is Sky High you
know what
me and you we got a long career ahead of
us we sure do stupid is still on Point
Security we got lots of job security
Jenny Craig and us we got a lot of work
to do this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host thank you for
joining us
next in Phoenix hey Heidi welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi it's so good to talk to you guys you
too what's up
uh my husband and I have we have our
mortgage here in Phoenix and then we
also have a paid for property that when
we moved we kept it and have rented it
out
and as we've talked about our finances
we're just trying to decide if
even though we both like the idea of the
rental if hanging on to that is holding
us back from because we could sell it
and pay off our home that we're living
in and have no mortgage which is the
only debt that we're holding on to but
the rental does bring in 1900 a month
and there's no mortgage on that property
so our idea was like down the road it's
going to be a great you know asset to
have bringing in income we just don't
want it to hold us back from progress
right now
okay what's your household income
get about 1 at 1 30 and
I bring in sometimes up to about 10 or
12. okay
let me tell you what's happened okay
um this did not occur
the reason it's bugging you here's the
reason it's bugging you this situation
did not occur as a result of an
intentional strategy
it occurred by default
you moved to Phoenix and rented out your
old place
right and so and we know that's true
because if you rent it in reverse you
would never do it meaning let's try this
where's the where's the rental again
it's in Utah okay let's pretend let's
pretend we were living in Phoenix with a
really nice paid for house
and someone came up and said hey go
borrow on your house and buy a rental in
Utah
you would laugh at them
yeah okay but you actually you so you
didn't actually do that as a strategy
obviously but that's the net result of
having backed into this by default
that's why it's bothering you and what
that tells what that tells me is I would
sell the rental and pay off your house
uh-huh
it bothers me because if I if I'm you
and I have a mortgage in the whole on
the home that I'm living in and there
there's a house several states away
that's debt free somebody else is living
there I want the debt free mortgage I
want to live in the house that's debt
free that's the way I feel about it if
you were going to uh borrow on your home
to buy a rental that cash flowed 1900
you would do it in your own town
right yeah and so I'm going to sell it
I'm going to pay off your house and I'm
going to use your fabulous income and
this new peace of mind that you have to
say hey how quickly can we put aside 150
200 Grand and pay cash for a nice rental
in our area and let's begin if we like
rentals and you said you did then let's
start building up a rental portfolio a
little bit at a time you know how fast
you can do that without a house payment
it's really ridiculously fast with your
income I love that plan and the Peace of
Mind
you're really you you're just gonna
breathe deeper you're gonna sleep
differently I mean it really does happen
uh Dr John delone talks about this all
the time he quotes a famous psychologist
who says the body keeps the score yes
and when you carry stress even if you
don't even if you don't realize you're
carrying stress you're carrying stress
your and debt is stressed by definition
a small debt is small stress big debt
stress right but it's still stress and
so your body is storing that and and
what people don't realize is when you
have zero debt that releases all of that
kind of stress out of your body you
literally physically
physiologically yeah have a change
absolutely it's ridiculous and so that
that's why why we tell people we try to
make it funny and make it stick okay it
doesn't work in Phoenix but we would say
you know if you pay off your house take
off your shoes and walk out in the
backyard the grass feels different and
Phoenix would be sand but yeah I mean
that's you know but I mean we talk about
the cactus but we act like it doesn't
matter but one of the studies that we
did on the state of personal finance did
say that 50 percent of people have said
that their finances have had a negative
impact on their mental health yeah and
she's not got high stress no she doesn't
but she's just saying I want to be smart
yeah
that's a good good statement very good
statement Heidi and a good question so
that's what we would do in your case
um and it doesn't really matter if other
people think they're smart or not uh
what matters is how do you feel when
you're done with it how you gonna feel
when you pay off that house from breathe
Rhonda's where this Rhonda is in San
Antonio hi Rhonda how are you
better than we deserve what's up
yeah for 15 years and left to the
profession about five years ago so I
have three choices and how I can do this
I can wait for 11 years which I'll be 66
and I'll get about 1600 a month and
medical I'm eligible to purchase Medical
I can take it now
um in June early and get 650 a month
or I can take out the lump sum of 59 000
and roll into a Roth or some investment
um 11 years gives me medical which I'm
self-employed right now and I'm paying
for myself
so which one of those mathematically
sounds like a good plan
well I without running it I can't tell
you in detail for sure but here's what I
do know and it works almost every single
time I run my calculator like 97 of the
time okay if you take the 59 000
and you were to invest that in good
growth stock mutual funds and the stock
market has averaged 11.8 percent since
it began and you let's say it didn't do
that well and you only made ten percent
on it you're going to end up with more
than the other two options
because it will grow to enough in 11
years to give you more than sixteen
hundred dollars a month income and it
will today provide you right around 600
a month that's about what it would do so
it's about the same today on that now
here's how I know that that almost
always happens you're dealing with a
pension fund and pensions are regulated
highly by the federal government and
what they're allowed to invest in is
very limited and so they have to buy
regulation run these calculations at six
and a half or seven percent somewhere
right in that range
and so the income that your lump sum is
producing and it will grow to produce
will is all calculated on about seven
percent if you instead invest it at 10
or 11 percent
obviously you're going to be seven
percent and the income that it's going
to produce is going to be greater than
seven percent the other thing that
happens that just makes the formula
completely blow up
is you die
right when you die the pension
goes away completely
right when you die and there's 60 000 or
seven years from now there's a hundred
and twenty thousand or seven years after
that there's 240 000 which is probably
what's going to happen in your mutual
funds in an IRA that you transferred
this lump sum to when you die they don't
keep your money that goes to your heirs
it's private property so that blows the
map that would Trump health insurance
absolutely a quarter of a million
dollars probably Trump's health
insurance yeah sure that makes sense
yeah and so yeah you're going to be
buying your own health insurance
and you would not do the 650 monthly and
then just invest that yeah
I did you said eight percent even in a
Roth but even with the fact that you
know I wouldn't go to a Roth because a
Roth is going to make this taxable
oh really it's earned income
it is
if you can roll it to a Roth without it
being taxed but I don't think you can I
think it has to go to a traditional to
keep it from being taxed you have to go
to Ira okay yeah Roth IRA I don't know
that yeah click click Ramsay Solutions
click on the smartvester pro and sit
down with one of them they'll help you
do the rollover and they can advise you
and tell you exactly what's going to
happen and they can even run these
numbers to show you and if it doesn't
turn out the way I'm saying
um
but it will I would be shocked yeah then
yeah I mean that because it's just the
regulations put this together make sure
you go do it this way so yeah you're
better off if you're alive and you're a
whole lot better when you die and Tennis
you're not better but your heirs are
better they either get zero or if you
live 14 years it's a quarter million
yeah I'm yeah option three
for the win ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding yeah yeah yeah the um
and
what's interesting is she's a teacher
obviously but
78 of the companies have done away with
pensions pensions are almost gone yeah
almost no one in the private sector
offers a pension about the only place
you still find it is in the Antiquated
governmental
Halls of stupidity it's not shocking
yeah so yeah I mean so teachers have it
you know but you don't find you know
going to work for a tech company they
don't offer you pensions they don't just
don't do it it's that simple
hope that helps you folks
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade
Washington Ramsay personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
thank you for being with us America
Nicole is with us in Bozeman Montana hi
Nicole Welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave indeed thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
oh my husband and I are planning to move
abroad for two years then return back to
Bozeman Montana and we're trying to
figure out what to do with our townhouse
we purchased our town home in April of
2020 right before things went crazy here
for three hundred ten thousand dollars
we currently owe 225 on it and have an
interest rate of 2.6 percent our monthly
payments 1950 which is right at a
quarter of our take home pay we had our
realtor come to our house last week they
said that they would list it right at
500 000 on I called a handful of
property management companies that said
we could rent it for about 3 000 a month
and I'm just trying to wrap my head
around if we sell it which I think is
what you're going to say we should do
um I'm just nervous that when we come
back even like with the equity that we
get from selling it that we wouldn't be
able to afford something that would put
us at a 15
um
15-year fixed rate mortgage at a quarter
of our take-home pay because of the
interest rates
um the interest rates and even just I
mean we bought
we bought it um
what you bought it for doesn't matter
what you sell for is what matters so if
you sell it for 500 and prices don't go
up
then the only difference in your payment
would be a higher interest rate
the interest rate and um I mean our
realtor told us to expect about 12 to go
to closing costs and things like that
and then once we pay off what we
currently own I'm assuming that if we
sold it at 500 we take home about 215.
um so if we came back and bought
something at 500 that's still um that
would be a larger mortgage it's a 12
swing Max
I mean your six percent realtor
commission typically and you've got
other missile in his closing costs so
you know 10 12 swing but that's assuming
prices don't go up okay so really you're
only so you know your biggest issue is
of interest rates stay right now where
they are they're double what you're
paying now
correct yes payment's not double but the
interest rate's double
and you think you're not going to be
able to get as much house for your money
am I hearing that right
um that's my concern yeah um I mean just
like a lot of other places in the
country things here are pretty crazy
um I'd love to see it change I just
don't think it will I just don't feel
good about you going out of the country
and having a rental I mean that that
gives me more anxiety okay so if if when
you come back your income will not have
changed
what are you doing when you're going for
two years you're on the mission field or
what are you doing
no we're planning to move to New Zealand
my husband's an electrician and
electricians are on a long-term job
shortage list over there so we'd be
moving over he'd be doing electrical
work um I'd be able to get a job once we
get there we don't have kids or anything
right now I'm 29 so before we so are you
going to is he going to be making a lot
more
is your income going to be up way up
while you're there
our income will be up but the
but so we're doing this why but it's
going to cost for renting and stuff I'm
doing this because we want to go to New
Zealand
even more reason to sell
because I mean I want to hear the end of
this hold on a second why are you going
yeah we've been working your debt
snowball plan so we've paid off our debt
and we're we don't have kids like I said
right now so before we settle down to
start trying first so it's a break it's
a break even Adventure
yeah it's an adventure for Break Even to
get to live in New Zealand for two years
to have a fun time
yeah okay all right cool
and then when you come back you'll be
doing back to your old jobs probably
and these are a Max two-year contract
and then New Zealand boots you out right
um the work visas up to three years that
we're planning on two okay and then
we'll be so max would be three anyways
so if real estate prices go up some
which we're projecting when we did our
real estate reality last year uh the
stream we projected and we shared with
you guys projections and the reasons for
them uh that we would see somewhere
around a seven or an eight percent
increase in prices in 23 across the
board in the United States some areas
more some areas less but that's across
the board uh as of February it's 7.8
percent so we're dead on okay 24 is
supposed to be a little less
and typically it's five to ten percent
increase in prices is normal year in and
year out in real estate somewhere in
that range obviously we've seen
craziness now what we have seen the
biggest thing you've got is not the um
for for returning with the same income
no more money the 12 you know the loss
of some of your Equity is not that big a
deal it's 40 50 Grand that's not going
to keep you from doing the deal uh the
biggest issue is our interest rates
going to come down while you're gone
to where you can get a similar price
because right now the the six percent
rate is going to make a bigger
difference uh in your payment than the
prices will okay so I'm not worried
about you repurchasing for price
increases I am a little bit worried
about your repurchasing on interest
rates if they continue to rise or if
they went down while you're gone in that
two years I don't know what's going to
happen there I have no clue to be honest
with you
um now what were you going to ask that I
was missing I I just wondered
um you know you're talking about going
abroad this is something you want to do
I
is there an a I mean your plan is to
stay for two years but if you end up
really liking it and you can stay three
years I just feel like there's a lot of
variables that
when you're Tethered to this property
um
it kind of keeps you
tethered down yeah okay here's the thing
I'm going to New Zealand and I'm selling
the house now let me tell you why I did
that
because your reason for going is to live
an adventure
your reason for going is taken away from
you if you are long distance landlording
from freaking New Zealand to Bozeman
okay some idiot will change his heart
Harley Oil in your living room yeah okay
and this is what happens when you long
distance landlord even with a property
manager and you're you know all of so
you can't have the adventure
and still try to have the stability at
home it's not going to give you the
adventure we're trying to get the
adventure
with the adventure comes freedom and the
freedom from this house and then just
deal with life when you come home figure
out what it is I don't know exactly what
it's going to be it could be higher
prices could be higher interest rates
prices could come down which would mean
I was wrong interest rates could come
down which I have no idea whether that
happens or not I wouldn't be wrong
because I didn't make a prediction there
but that that's the thing so I do the
adventure if you're going to do the
adventure girl don't do the I'm going to
have stability back home and Adventure
this is two different girls be the
adventure girl or be the stability girl
back home and don't go that's a good
point but don't you can't have both it's
not going to work for you yep because
it's gonna what you're not realizing is
the stress of continued home ownership
in the midst of this is not worth what
the the transaction it's taking away
from the adventure so I kind of think
what you're doing is fun I just wish you
were doubling your income while you're
in New Zealand that would have made it
super fun like the people that do stuff
are going to Dubai for a year or
something that's going to the sandbox
boxer to do whatever that's serious
money there but if you're gonna do it
yeah but but hey
maybe it'll turn out that way maybe I
don't know but sell it if you're gonna
go that's what I would do this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phone's a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Hey listen up our smart conference
weekend the inaugural event for the new
Ramsay Event Center which they're
putting the finishing touches on as we
speak they're out there rolling outside
right now which costs more than gold
oh yeah it's gonna be beautiful it is
beautiful already tickets have been
going fast we've got just a handful left
uh a little less than 100 tickets so if
you want to come to the weekend it's
April 14th and 15th it's going to be a
uniquely
Nashville weekend uh we'll do the show
and stuff at the brand new event center
on Friday we've got some of our good
country music friends that we've gotten
to know over the 30 years we've lived
here that are going to stop by and say
howdy to you guys and play a tune for
you that kind of stuff and then all day
on Saturday we're having uh wonderful
teachings on Mental Health on career on
money on every part of your
relationships every part of your life
it's going to be an incredible
incredible smart conference all the
Ramsey personalities will be on the
stage uh we're going to do events we're
going to do live podcasts from there uh
it's you're going to get their
commemorative badge for the opening
event you're there for the inaugural
event this is all Nashville yeah live
music in the whole bit tickets start as
low as 119 dollars but again there's
just a few left they're just about gone
so if you really want your tickets you
need to get them like yesterday jump on
there and now we don't hype this stuff
we don't almost sell it out and then
tell you listen is like I saw the report
a while ago comes through I'm the CEO
okay I get the reports on these things
there's actually 74 tickets left okay
that's exactly how many left they less
than 100 it is 74. that's what's left
okay and as I finish speaking it's
probably going down so there you go
ramseysolutions.com events
ramsaysolutions.com events now if you
didn't know there's a very large I can't
even remember how many is in there now
it's probably approaching right at a
million folks now in the baby steps
community
private Facebook group not real private
if there's almost a million people in
there but it's a massive thing
and uh we've been having some fun with
this Rebecca at the Ramsay baby steps
Community made the following post and
here are some of the responses she says
you know you listen to Dave Ramsey when
number one your kids know the call-in
phone number AAA 825-5225
look at you off the memory man I don't
know you were a listener for a long time
before you came here I think so but if
my kids could say it that might be this
is funny you think of the Costco hot dog
as splurging a dollar fifty you might be
a Dave Ramsey I love this one oh and
we've seen this your first date turns
into an FPU in a nutshell oh yeah
[Laughter]
let's see I like this kids ask if it's
in the budget yeah that's true that one
definitely I would love my kids to ask
that your child repeats debt is dumb
cash is King to everyone he knows
oh this one had a picture with it your
child thinks one of the Minecraft
characters on his pajamas looks like
George camel
you know why because it looks like
George camel there you go I love this
you can't watch Braveheart anymore
without hearing Dave's laughing in an
otherwise serious moment of the film
I've been there yeah when he yells
freedoms when he gets his head cut off
you remember the end of the movie that's
it I mean it's like Freedom yeah it's
like that's that's what we use for the
debt-free scream yeah it's like I don't
know yeah I agree with that love it I
love this one you start using words like
whoopty doopy I love when you say stupid
butt that's my favorite bass backwards
yeah plasectomy hoopty that's one of my
favorites stupid texts yeah this one you
know somebody started doing this years
ago you might be a redneck if you might
Listen to Too Much Dave Ramsey or Ramsey
show if rice and beans is a five course
dinner okay yeah love it oh this is my
favorite Bakersfield comes on at the
pool while on vacation and one of your
kids yells we paid cash Dave that's I
told I was telling Dave earlier my kids
like the movie sing and in the movie
sing one of the characters yeah one of
the characters is playing Baker Street
on his saxophone and my son goes Mama
that that's Dave Ramsey's music
yes Rafferty might take offense to that
yeah right I know well there it is it's
my music but um but yeah well you're
drinking the Kool-Aid we've uh yeah you
got you've kind of got it all dialed
down at that point that's for sure
hey thanks for joining us America this
is your show it's common sense for your
life and your dollars and cents open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Justin is with us in
Atlanta hi Justin welcome to the Ramsay
show
thank you for having me how are you
better than I deserve what's up
uh so I kind of got a
um a decision I'm wrestling with and I
was hoping maybe uh you know uh you guys
could uh uh you know help me help me
with that so what I got here is
um
in my work uh my employer
you know um basically gave me the option
um for a company uh vehicle
or a vehicle allowance
I'm just you know just trying to figure
out which is you know the best for me
which is the wildest decision there what
do you do
um so I'm in project management and
estimating for a mechanical contractor
how many miles a year you put on this
vehicle
I've been in this role for two years and
averages about 16 000 miles a year
so not much
that's not much
that's below average okay or brought
around average I guess something like
that how much is the allowance
uh 700 a month
um it is taxed so after it gets taxed
it's like 600 net okay let's start with
let's back up two steps and give you the
premise okay number one under no
circumstances do you go buy a car with
car payments
correct if you're paying cash for the
car and they're going to give you 700 we
can think about it all right now uh
here's the thing what we often don't
think about is if you bought well if you
bought a car how expensive a car would
you buy
or you have a car
I have a car yeah okay so you could just
take seven hundred dollars
I can I mean it's good it's old it's an
old car um okay if you got any money to
buy a better car
um I've got about five grand outside of
my emergency fund okay so you can move
up five grand in car but we're not doing
car payments you got that Justin right
correct because if you lose the job you
still got the car payments and you don't
have the dadgum 700 anymore
yeah and that's some people all the time
take a car allowance and use that as an
excuse to get a car payment that's dumb
but that's horrible thinking
all right so we're not doing that but
now once we get past that then what
we're doing is we're doing just a math
analysis on the ownership of a vehicle
if you were putting 60 000 miles on the
thing or something I would just tell you
take their car company car because you
cannot where you cannot operate a
vehicle and put 60 000 miles on it with
the depreciation that's going to occur
and the maintenance that's going to
occur with that kind of heavy miles uh
on 700 bucks you can't do it all right
so you'd be better off to drive their
car now in your case you're not putting
many miles on it and this just sounds
like they're giving you some kind of a
benefit because you've been doing a good
job
which is nice right okay
um I've worked up to this yeah yeah
good for you that's a compliment to you
so well done uh
thank you so what you've got to figure
out is is let's say you your current car
is worth what
I think 6 500 bucks okay so buy a 12 000
car you pay cash for it all right now
what's going to happen to that twelve
thousand dollar car
and you got 700 a month to cover it now
if they give you the company car does
that include insurance I'm sure it does
it includes maintenance I'm sure it does
uh Does it include fuel
yes I would get a fuel card either way
either way okay so that's a break even
on the fuel okay wow nice offer all
right so the question is can we drive a
12 000 car
for 700 a month in Lost value yes you
can
because you're not gonna lose that much
value it's the 12 000 car and so yeah as
long as you keep the car cheap
uh I'm taking the money but if you're
going to put a high miles on it or
you're going to try to do an expensive
car then you're much better off to take
their car because you take a fifty
thousand dollar car You're Gonna Lose
seven hundred dollars a month and value
just by it sitting in the driveway
so you know that that's the kind of crap
you're dealing with there so you're not
got a lot of loss of value which is your
primary problem and you've got your
repairs covered I'm probably taking the
money and driving 12 000 car if I'm you
good question and congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
okay Ramsey personality is my co-host
today in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt free stage John and Carolyn
are with us hey guys how are you we're
doing well welcome welcome where do you
live we live in Whitehall Wisconsin ah
welcome to Nashville long way from
Wisconsin it is so uh how much have you
paid off we paid off 160 hang on 166
000 in 29 months way to go very good and
your range of income during that time it
was 83 000 to 101. cool what do you all
do for a living I work in accounting at
uh pilgrims
I'm a stay-at-home mom very cool very
cool what kind of debt was your 166 000
it was our house
look at a weird people all right way to
go where are those I love it so proud of
y'all what's this house worth uh we
looked on Zillow the other day it was
about 232. awesome how old are you guys
I'm 36 and I'm 32 and we paid it off
just the day before he turned 36. all
right well happy birthday right oh
that's pretty cool yeah man who would
have ever thought at the U2 at 36 years
old have paid four house and 32 years
old way to go well we were trying to do
his 40th birthday but we uh got a little
ahead of her you got you got you go you
got a little fire around
tell us what happened what got you guys
started on this whole idea uh two and a
half years ago well uh I bought the
house about six months before we got
married so actually I'm in the 20 that
you mentioned earlier
she let you keep the house I love the
house yeah and a couple months after we
got married we were uh we read your
Total Money Makeover book neither of us
know how it got there though
um some mystery indeed yeah we were just
looking for a book to read out loud to
each other we'd been married about eight
weeks and we were just like hey it'd be
fun to read aloud to each other and he's
like well what do you want to read and I
was like well pick something off our
bookshelf he's like how about this book
and I was like sure and uh and then we
were talking about it later and I was
like where did that book even come from
we're like one of your parents snuck
into your house I think God ordained it
that that book was on our bookshelf for
a reason yeah we do that we sneak in
people's houses and leave them there
yeah and then they just discover them
yeah way to go you guys that's cool so
you start reading Total Money Makeover
and you go what have happen then in your
brain all right well um we grew up in
normal families uh they had like
mortgages and Consumer Debt and we uh
then had a family over from church and
they were uh talk about how they were
planning to pay off their house the next
year and they were like well we've had
our house for like 30 years and uh paid
more in interest than the house is worth
so we were like we don't want to be like
that yeah we had just finished reading
the book and after they left we just
looked at each other and were like no we
don't want to do that nope nope nope not
us wow so you read the book it hit home
and you started making changes did you
make any changes to your your everyday
life in order to make this happen and if
so like what were those changes because
we say all the time you know sometimes
it's not about that same intensity but
you get intentional about it right so
what did that look like for you well we
adjusted we also we did adjust our uh
contributions a little bit we went out
to eat a little bit less watched what we
were buying with like groceries and
stuff like that I also had some uh some
stock some individual stock and I sold
all that and threw it all at the house I
love that how much of the 166 was that
uh about 80. oh wow so that jump started
big time oh yes yeah so it was just a
matter of let's take what we've got and
reorganize it to hit our goal yeah right
what must be true indeed and then you
pick 80 grand and you just knock that
out in 30 months with your incomes and
the earlier you're done the earlier the
better I know that's right so how does
it feel
well we haven't gotten to uh feel the
grass beneath our feet but the snow
feels cold
snow angels in the backyard to celebrate
yeah indeed very good good job guys all
right so um what do you tell people the
key is now uh accountability and
budgeting with like sticking to your
budget like laying out telling every
dollar where you want it to go and then
my wife here was the
my biggest accountability partner I did
some budgeting before I got married but
it was oh I'm gonna make the budget and
then I come back to like four months
later and yeah so okay so she she kind
of turned she she was the one that
managed the system and then you all both
worked the system no not necessarily
just I'm the nerd but okay
I she's the one who provided
accountability and actually got me there
holding each other accountable okay you
know hey we want to go out to eat but we
already used up our eating out budget so
we're not yeah
yeah we choose to pay off our house yeah
yeah we still one more steak yeah very
good yeah I like it I like it I like it
I like it congratulations thank you
thank you way to go we really appreciate
appreciate what you've done in our lives
wow you did it all we did show you how
you're the heroes and you got the babies
what age are your babies well you got uh
we got Terry who's uh 19 months and
Harrison is four months we'll put them
in the picture here to do the debt free
scream we've got to live and give uh
bundle for you and that includes the
baby steps millionaires book you're on
your way to that The Total Money
Makeover book it can mysteriously appear
in one of your friend's house and uh of
course Financial Peace University a
membership to that if you hadn't done it
go ahead and do it if not give it away
we actually just got done um
you're leading it thank you yeah well
you're gonna be great leaders I mean 36
and 32 with paid for a house you can't
really argue with these people I have a
different Theory we don't care yeah
listen to these folks they know what
they're doing yeah it's very very cool
but what these uh young men don't
realize because they're not old enough
to even grash but is that you've
completely changed their family tree I
mean this is a Godly Man losing
inheritance to his children's children
you have put yourself in a position to
change everything so very proud of you I
mean if we just could multiply that
couple right there all over America we
could change this whole country pretty
amazing well done you guys very very
very well done all right John and
Caroline Terry and Harrison from
Wisconsin 166
000 paid off in 29 months making 83 to
101 count it down let's zero debt free
screams
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
oh this is how it's done boys and girls
you gotta love it
you gotta love it man
you know when I first started teaching
this stuff I was
convinced that I was debt-free because I
was and I was convinced I would never
borrow money again because I wouldn't
but I'd been through hell
we'd lost everything we've been through
everything and I didn't know if I could
convince anyone else to really
do this idea of we're going to pay off
our house
and then I got a 36 year old 32 year old
in front of me and I've got this in
front of me almost every day of the week
these days uh people in their 20s and
their 30s paying off their homes because
here's what happens here's the thing if
you think just take I don't know two
thousand dollar a month house payment
from age 32
to age 72. yeah that's millions and
millions of dollars in a mutual fund if
they just put what used to be a house
payment that's all they do they don't do
anything else yep in their 60s and 70s
they're going to be
multi-multi-multi-millionaires multiple
and and for the people listening who
sometimes go I don't want to wait till
I'm in my 60s and be a millionaire
they're going to be a millionaire before
that they're going to have some Millions
before because they're not going to just
do a house payment right but my point is
the power
of not having a house payment
mathematically yeah and the power of
investing the equivalent when Sharon and
I finally paid off our house years and
years and years ago we went back and
said man we're going to take that old
house payment now and we're gonna just
see what that put that one amount into a
mutual fund that mutual fund became a
million dollars so fast it was scary how
fast just that one fund that was one of
our Millions you know I mean it's just
it's blows your mind how this math Works
yes and and
don't just take our I mean yes take our
word for it but man like get on a
calculator get on an investment
calculator like start playing with those
numbers and seeing it I know for me
that's what I needed to do because you
hear people talk about it and and
there's still this piece of your brain
that's like it's but is it really
possible yes it is well Albert Einstein
said that you know compound interest is
the eighth wonder of the world those who
understand it earn it those who don't
pay it
and that's you know hello good word
Albert rich people ask how much more
people ask how much down how much a
month that's how this works good stuff
man what a cool couple really really
cool I'm just looking at him changing
your life changing your family tree
that's fun anyone can do it this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
scripture of the day Ecclesiastes one
and nine of what has been is what will
be and what has been done is what will
be done and there's nothing new Under
the Sun Paul Harvey said in times like
these it helps to recall that there have
always been
times like these
love it
this is true crazy's always been on the
block all right Jill is with us Jill is
in Spokane Washington hi Jill how are
you
oh hi Dave hi Jay thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
quick question
um my father passed away a few months
ago and one of his Brokers or financial
people called me today
he had an IRA with them and he was going
over the options of either cashing it
out or putting it in a hair inherited
IRA of bird have to be
um
down to zero in ten years correct and
wondering what you think is the best
option
do you have any debt
no
not at all
none how much do you have in savings
okay what do you plan to do with that
um we're actually we're both retired so
we're just kind of living on off of it
right now okay
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry about your dad
how old was he
actually was born
wow okay yeah
yeah
um
how much is in the inherited IRA
okay
all right well as he said you had to
Bullet out 1600 a year and be taxed on
it as you pull it out or you just pull
it out now and you're taxed on it
um right
what I would do has nothing to do with
the math it has to do with you guys are
financially in great shape and sixteen
thousand is not making any movement
whatsoever in your life one way or the
other and right so what I'm going to do
is just to limit the hassle I don't want
to mess with it for 10 years I'm just
going to cash it out
that has nothing to do with the math
that's just I don't mess with it
right just be done with it you know if
it was a million six you know I might
fool with it because the taxes are going
to be substantial but the taxes on 16
000 is going to be three or four
thousand bucks and we're done we don't
think about it again you know and so you
take the money and go do add it to your
savings go do with whatever you want to
do with it do something in his memory or
you know something that he would have
thought was fun go do that I don't care
whatever it is you want to do but
um I'm just doing that on a I try to do
things just to keep things really simple
these days I have enough complexity to
my life without adding little knitsy
things you know what I'm saying
no I appreciate that yes
so that's that's probably the direction
I'm going but um
um but if I'm you but there's no math
behind that direction it's simply the uh
the minimalist my friends the minimalist
the way of living I just don't want to
deal with junk you know I want to deal
with stuff so
um not not like I really live a
minimalist life I don't but uh I do have
more shirts than black shirts that's all
they wear is black shirts but they uh
they're friends of ours and they do a
great job we love their stuff but the
the point being that simplify simplify
simplify you know when you can when in
doubt now again if you were broke and
you needed the money or you didn't have
any Investments going we might try to
drag it out turn into you know some kind
of get a little bit complicated with it
might be worth it but in her world it's
not much money I agree with that yeah I
would do the same thing good stuff now
here's what the new secure act says used
to be that if you inherited an IRA some
of you got one three years ago or
something okay you had different rules
but if someone passed away in 2020 or
later
then what you're going to have is uh
January uh If you inherited an IRA on or
before January 1st 2020 the new law does
not apply to you but after that the new
law says you inherit an IRA whatever it
is it all has to come out in 10 years
so ten percent a year for 10 years it
has to be emptied in 10 years because
the government wants their money and
there's taxes due on that when it comes
out so they're it's like the required
minimum distribution that's there it
requires you to pull it out beginning
now it's 73 and there's a formula that
requires you to cash out traditional
IRAs not Roth IRAs but traditionals and
this is on the traditional is the only
thing we're talking about here because
Roth there's no taxes on anyway you just
take it out you don't have to worry
about it but we're trying are we forced
to take it out and pay the taxes now
well today if it's if it's someone that
passes after January 1st to 2020
secure act says
this is the original skir act not 2.0
but it still it still says 10 years you
got 10 years to do it Andrew is with us
in Santa Barbara hi Andrew welcome to
the Ramsey show what's up
Hey sir um I just wanted to you know I
want to be weird like you guys talk
about um I heard that I hear the BET
free screens all the time
um you know we want to get to that point
my wife and I
um fortunately we don't own a house
right now
um so that's something later down the
road that we'll get to um but we just
started spu a couple weeks ago uh we got
step one knocked out we're in step two
right now way to go um and uh speaking
of baby steps you know we have a baby on
the way
um our our first we're expecting
congrats
thank you appreciate it uh and so we're
just you know while we're paying that
debt off we want to make sure that we're
also trying to you know start saving up
for kids for the kiddo
um because kids are expensive you know I
have a five-year-old from my first
marriage so I realized how expensive
kids are so I just didn't know if you
guys had any advice on while we're
working on baby step two you know how
can how can we kind of start stuffing
away bits and pieces here and there to
get the kiddo started off right yeah how
much debt are you working to pay off
uh total combined
um I mean we really don't have a lot
honestly so we have the car as our
biggest one we we're about 23 on that um
and then about uh 1200 bucks on a credit
card
um so you know we've got maybe 24 total
in debt that we got to pay off what's
your income
um
we get about 2 800 every two weeks I'm
on
um salary she's on time card so it kind
of buries a little bit with her time
about 5600 a month is what we average
okay you know uh
a lot of times we would say to pause the
baby steps or pause the debt snowball
while you're waiting for a baby to
arrive you know we want to make sure
that there's so many variables with
babies arriving in this world so we want
to make sure that you've got the money
to cover it I mean obviously you're
going to be paying your deductible out
of pocket that sort of thing and um you
know
stack up all that money all the money
that you would have
go ahead I'm sorry I didn't mean to cut
you off yet so the good thing um the the
uh birth itself I'm in the military so
Healthcare
um will cover the the entire birth wow
great that we don't have to worry about
paying for anything for the birth we
just wanted to you know start still you
know stuffing away things for I mean
because kids grow out of diapers you
know you don't need money for that you
need to budget for that what's your due
date yes
uh August 12th right now congratulations
this is a wonderful time for y'all thank
you thank you for your service so I'm
still going to do what Jade suggested
Andrew there's no downside to it here's
what I want you to do I want you to keep
working your budget with the same
intensity that you were going to work it
for paying off debt the only difference
is pay minimum payments on everything
and pile up as big a pile of cash as you
can pile up how much do you think you
can pile up between now and August 12th
10 000 bucks oh
I would say at least yeah if we're if
we're going to keep on track let's call
it let's call it fifteen thousand okay
so 15 000 is piled up and baby comes
military pays all the medical expenses
there's no problems baby comes home Mama
comes home no problems take fifteen
thousand put it on pay off your uh
Stupid low card and uh then put the rest
of it on the car and then we'll finish
up the car by Christmas okay you're
going to be out of debt I think almost
within a minute or two the same speed as
if you just pay down the debt but what
this gives you is fifteen thousand
dollars worth of breathing room with a
brand new baby coming it just in case
something weird is going on right and
the key is don't don't cool out your
intensity just because you're not making
those payment those extra payments every
month right keep keep going hard at it I
push pause and pile up cash use the cash
to catch back up right right to where
you would have been
but that gives you this breathing room
because in case something happens is too
important an event to to have to not
have a margin right now that's what we
would do that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]